vous n'êtes pas français pas de français
vous avez pas de Tyt de séjour et ben à
un moment faut voà jeune quand je bah
c'est la France qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m'aé vous détenez euh des éléments qui
contredisent totalement le constat de
Luissier venu chez France Télévision
alors c'est mieux que ça
ah c'est plus simple vous savez qu quand
vous voulez mettre un terme une
polémique quand vous voulez convaincre
je vais pas me servir de mes pièces
parce que on pourra toujours dire ah il
faut qu'on a le temps de les vérifier il
faut qu'on puisse les analyser où ça se
trouve ces pièces sont infondées si vous
voulez vraiment gagner c'est comme au
judo vous vous servez de la force
deadversaire et donc des pièces
deadversaire là je me sers et je ne
m'appuie que sur les pièces de France
Télévision à savoir leurs images qui ont
été diffusées et leur constat puisque
personne n'a vu le constat
excepté leur partenaire France Info il y
a que France Info qui a publié des
extraits de ce constat d'accord et donc
il est très important et on va y aller
point par point puisque en effet ce qui
a provoqué la chute de l'ogre puisque
c'était le but puisque c'est le titre
quand même de ce sujet donc la chute de
Gérard de pardieu c'est pas les blagues
à i de mauvais goût soit sal Lass pour
certaines qu'on lui a demandé de faire
en tant que personnage dans le film l'OM
mage cinématographique de yx puisquon a
les contrats de fiction c'est le fait et
je reprends la voix off de complément
d'enquête le fait qu'il ait sexualisé un
enfant ex et en effet le fait d'avoir
sexualisé un enfant vous glace ou et si
on considère que c'est vraiment le
Gérard pardieu dans l'intimité dans la
vie réelle c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment disqualifie socialement et donc
vous avez la première image alors on va
revenir dans son procès verbal donc
luisser constate que tous les propos
contesté ont bien été tenus dans le ara
à ce moment-là et surtout il l'indique
c'est ce qui dit Luissier mais Luissier
Luissier il regarde les images va
regarder il va dire bah c'est cy c'est
pas un expert Luissier c'est c'est un
huissier c'est bien ce que ça veut dire
Bernard Montiel était huissier voilà
donc il constaté voilà comme ici il
vient dans l'émission il constate au
cours de cette séquence donc je constate
qu'à l'exception de la jeune F seul des
cavaliers d'apparence masculine entrent
en premier plan des caméras voilà alors
ça c'est très important ça c'est
l'extrait du icier publié par France
Info et en effet on se dit à lire cela
que à l'exception de la jeune fille donc
de l'enfant il n'y a que des hommes et
l'image d'après ça vient sur une voie
off Gérard de pardieu sexualise l'enfant
et vous avez l'image sur laquelle on
voit cette petite entouré de trois
hommes un cavalier et deux moniteurs
derrière où il est écrit si on peut voir
l'image à l'antenne si jamais il Galoppe
elle jouit oui donc là bien évidemment
avec ce que annonce Luissier on se dit
tous bah il l'a dit oui bien sûr sauf
que faut lire d'un peu plus près ce que
dit Luissier et c'est pour ça que votre
régie a eu raison de souligner luisser
dit en premier plan parce que je
rappelle quand même que l'uissier c'est
un officier ministériel il peut ne pas
tout dire il peut mentir par omission
mais ne peut pas mentir sinon là c'est
automatiquement une condation il perd
son titre d'accord et ça ça a attiré
notre attention pourquoi parce que en
premier plan ça veut dire qu'il y a
peut-être un second plan c'est ça et ça
c'est il constate les images qu'on lui a
donné et il constate et il dit moi en
premier plan je le vois que des enfants
un enfant et trois hommes est-ce qu'il y
a un second plan et c'est intéressant
alors on se pose la question on
recherche est-ce qu' fait l'analyse du
second plan s'il le précise c'est qu'il
y a un second plan et là c'est très
curieux parce que il ne dit rien mais y
a autre chose c'est que Luissier ne
constate pas cette fameuse phrase si
jamais il galopee elle jouit alors que
le monde qui est aussi un grand soutien
de complément d'enquête ainsi que France
Info partenaire de complément d'enquête
indique que les images qui eux ils ont
vu du film de Part Dieu dit oh c'est
bien madame si jamais elle galope elle
jouit et attention inf il dit Madame oh
c'est bien
madame si jamais elle galopeppe elle
jouit et complément d'enquête qui a
comme partenaire France Info donne
encore plus d'informations à leur
partenairire et ces derniers écrivent
oui en effet il dit ça il dit même oh
c'est bien madame si jamais elle galope
elle jouit s'il l'a fait galopper elle
mouille elle jouit et là on se dit
mais comme l'a dit le monde il parle de
cette petite
y MOX a toujours soutenu que Gérard
Dedieu n'a jamais à aucun moment de la
séquence parler et sexualiser cette
petite alors Monsieur max vous êtes bien
aimable mais moi j'ai un constat
dehissier qui me dit qu'il y a que des
hommes à part une petite fille et j'ai
Gard de par que j'entends si jamais
galope elle jouit de qui parle-il il
parle d'une autre cavalière elle est où
cette are cavalière elle est au second
plan et voilà est-ce que on peut avoir
le second plan et si vous prenez image
par image vous avez est-ce qu'il y a une
femme dans le Hara et là vous avez une
cavalière ah oui qui je vous rappelle et
ça c'est très important à la différence
et vous pouvez faire image par image ou
alors le regarder chez vous puisque que
c'est encore en ligne à mon avis ça sera
plus
longtemps c'est la cavalière à la
différence on le voit avec la queue du
cheval à la différence de la petite qui
est sur un poney et ouis et n'est pas au
pas mais au trop comme chacun sa
notamment de par Dieu qui est quand même
fin connaisseur en matière d'équitation
qui a quand même joué à trè nombre de
films où il était cavalier en matière
d'équitation il y a plusieurs vitesses
nous avons le pas nous avons le trot et
à la suite du trot le Galot et donc
quand de par Dieu dit oh c'est bien
madame madame c'est une dame bien sûr si
jamais elle galopee donc puisquelle est
au trop si elle passe à la vitesse
supérieure elle jouit ça c'était ce que
lui avait demandé MOX de dire tu es le
beauf qui commmente des cavalières et
voilà voilà et voilà elle passe donc si
jamais son moniteur l'a fait passer au
Galot c'est la deuxième phrase s'il l'a
fait galoper
elle mouille elle jouit et ce qui est
extraordinaire que non non mais je
termine juste une chose Monsieur si
jamais il galopee elle jouit c'est la
phrase qu'on voit sur l'écran de
complément d'enquête et ben figurez-vous
que cette phrase n'est pas dans le
constat duissier pourquoi elle est pas
dans le constat duissier par rapport à
l'image qui correspond à la petite
entourée de trois hommes parce que de
Part Dieu ne la prononce pas en
regardant la petite il la prononce en
regardant la cavalière qui est une
adulte donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a ce fameux plan de coupe
il y a ce sous-titre et y a la voix off
avant alors est-ce qu'on peut revoir
l'image euh pourtant parce que les
journalistes de complément d'enquête
pour eux il n'y avait pas de doute
d'ailleurs ils ont resserré l'image sur
la petite fille j'aimerais qu'on voit
l'image parce que eux ils font ce qu'on
vient de voir là ils viennent ils
resserrent en fait ils resserrent sur la
volontairement pour qu'on se dise euh et
toute façon toute façon ils se sont dit
ils verront jamais rien ils vont pas
revenir là-dessus ils vont pas faire une
enquête là-dessus et ils Savit pas que
ça allait faire un un un BZ comme ça il
l'espéit tout mê puisque ils l'ont quand
même mis en
teaser pour annoncer le complément
d'enquête mais il n'y a pas que ça
vous avez les téléspectateurs disent
déjà c'est fou comment on peut
trafiquer c'est pour ça qu'on accorde
une confiance extrêmement importante à
aux producteurs de télévision et au
télédiffuseur et que en cas de
manquement même non intentionnel ils
sont sévèrement sanctionnés mais en cas
de manquement intentionnel ils sont
gravement sanctionnés qui plus sur le
service public mais là ce n'est pas
c'est pas le tout c'est que puisqu'on a
des extraits bien sûr de Luissier allons
allons allons tout lire là j'ai plus de
Madame ils ont fait disparaître le
madame puisque sinon tout le monde
aurait eu le même réflexe que nous
pourquoi il parle de madameev le madamei
si Madame si oh c'est bien madame si
jamais elle galope elle jou il y a plus
de Madame c'est grave ça ont suppré la
il sousentendre qui
s'adressa vous n'avez pas vous n'avez
pas que
cela'avez pas que cela c'est supprim le
madame ça c'est sûr à partir du moment
où vous avez un premier plan de caméra
et on voit qu'il y a un deuxiè plan de
caméra on va regarder vraiment le
deuxième plan de caméra et là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que cet huissier
qui vraiment évite les obstacles
puisqu'il sait que son constat va être
exploité par France Télévision et va
être public je rappelle quand même que
comme par extraordinaire personne n'a le
nom de cet huissier personne n'a le
constat mais personne n'a le nom de cet
huissier je rappelle que les huissiers
c'est un peu comme les avocats ils sont
rarement en manque de publicité he s'ils
peuvent et je sais de quoi je parle
s'ils peuvent faire état un peu de leur
nom parce que ça ramène ça fait ça
génère une certaine notoriété là comme
par hasard c'est l'uisser le plus
discret de France j'espère que toutes
ces images vont être reprises par les
autres médias bien sûr mais bien
évidemment mais de toute façon si c'est
pas reprise par les autres médias en
tout cas ça sera reprise par le
procureur de la républ voilà bravo ce
qui est très important c'est que c
huissier travaillons avec lui c huissier
nous nous indique que il y a à minima
deux caméras et lui il constate deux
caméras professionneles avec des time
code donc on peut comparer bien sûr il
refuse de les images et de donner accès
aux bandes pourquoi puisque la bande
audio avec la bande image on pourra voir
si elle matche si elle ne matche pas il
y a bel et bien montage et donc trucage
en l'espèce vous avez la deuxième
difficulté quand même dans ce complément
d'enquête en ce qui concerne la position
de Lian max il a jamais sexualisé la
petite fille écoutez c'est un peu gênant
monsieur parce que il y a quand même un
constat duiciier qui dit on voit la
jeune fille sur un équidé guidé par un
homme après après cette séquence juste
quelques secondes après
ou monsieur de par Dieu ça c'est
Luissier qui je lis le constat duier
monsieur de pardieu dit c'est bien ma
fille fille continue tu vois elle se
gratte là Monsieur de pardieu dis c'est
bien et là j'ai souvenir que Julie de
pardieu très naturellement avec une
immense sincérité a dit mais vous savez
mon père appelle Fifi tout le monde peut
appeler Fifi une vieille dame une jeune
dame une femme c'est ridicule mais
quelle défense et Cera et inconsciemment
nous aussi on se dit Fifi c'est plus
pour un enfant qu'une adulte d'autant
que quand on regarde cette
séquence on ne voit que le moniteur et
la petite quand il dit tu vois elle se
gratte première observation moi
personnellement je vois pas personne se
grat mais surtout je me dis même si ils
ont manipulé monté le si galope si
jamais mal joui il reste là alors la
question c'est est-ce qu'il parle de la
petite est-ce qu'il parle de l'enfant il
y a de moi m'a assuré que non et je suis
convaincu qu'il a raison pourquoi parce
que voyez-vous toujours sur l'huissier
qui se fait un plaisir de nous dire je
vois caméra
1 ce que le l'équipe de tournage filme
et caméra 2 elle filme d'autres un autre
angle bah voyez-vous quand je vous ai lu
le constat duiciier donc la
retranscription tu vois elle se gratte
c'est la caméra 2 et lui met entre
guillemets sur la caméra 2 on voit la
petite fille sur équidé guidée par un
homme trois petits points je sais pas ce
qu'il y a entre les trois petits points
monsieur de pardu dit c'est bien ma
fifille continue tu vois elle se gratte
là trois petits
points soit est-ce que je peux avoir
l'analyse de la caméra une Paris que là
c'est la de si grat et là je l'ai pas
ouais ah ouais voir
gr imaginons une seconde que Gérard de
pardieu parlait toujours de la même
cavalière puisque c'était une espèce de
blague à répétition on en pense qu'on
veut mais ça arrive c'est ce qu'on peut
demander à chaque fois qu'elle passe
puisqu'elle est au trop elle passe bien
plus vite que la petite ouais chaque
fois qu'elle passe tu fais une
remarque c'est peut-être sur la caméra 2
et ben regardez de près d'image quand
vous regardez image par image en ce qui
concerne la petite c'est sur la base de
ces
images sur la base de ses propos que
Gérard de pardieu a
véritablement chuté pour reprendre leur
expression et a été même lyché et tout
le monde a perdu la raison puisque bien
on comprend on peut comprendre que dès
qu'on parle de des enfants et un adulte
qui sexualise sérieusement un enfant
dans ces CASL on considère qu'il n'a pas
à faire partie de notre communauté et
c'est une exclusion sociale et c'est
véritablement scandaleux et il moi
voudrais rajouter unuc en plus ils l'ont
balancé avant sur les réseaux sociaux
bien sûr un BZ énorme c'est ça c'est
dire que les gens ont parl avant
pas avec le même succès mais certains B
c'est un peu ce que vous faites merci
oui c'est vrai avec pas avec le même
succès merci en tout cas euh maîre
Assous ça a été incroyable he on avait
l'impression d'être dans fil et vraiment
on ne pensait pas avoir autant de
preuves parce que là les preuves je
trouve qu'elles sont irréfutables je ne
sais pas quelle va être la réponse de
complément d'enquête ni de France
Télévision mais là franchement pour moi
c'est rideau on va en pararler demain
bien entendu dans cette émission parce
qu'on va revenir sur tout ça est-ce que
vous avez un dernier truc à ajouter j'ai
j'ai quelque chose de très simple là
pour l'instant c'est n'est qu'une
analyse plus ou moins précise exhaustive
nous avons fait notre mieux de leur
pièce après nous avons les nôtres et
puis après vous allez quand même avoir
celle de la police puisque il va y avoir
une enquête puisque là vous pensez bien
qu'il y a des actions judiciaires qui
sont lancées contre complément d'enquête
enfin France Télévision et le producteur
Anthony Dufour et les réalisateurs de ce
sujet de complément d'enquête mais une
fois de plus je comprends beaucoup mieux
pourquoi ils s ont toujours refusé de
communiquer l'intégralité du CAT
pourquoi ils ont toujours refusé de
communiquer les rus et même à la police
pourquoi et qu'il nous disent pas oh
secret des sources bien évidemment le
secret des sources faut le respecter il
est extrêmement important il y a c'est
pas une source là c'est un sujet et qui
fait polémique dans lequel il y a de
véritables accusations qui sont portés
contre Gérard de par Dieu et on démontre
que ce n'est pas le cas et on peut pas
opposer le secret des sources à et donc
j'invite tout à chacun puisque nous
allons le faire à saisir
l'arcom demander que ils impose à France
Télévision et à film de se justifier et
de donner des explications et j'invite
également le gouvernement notamment le
ministre tutel de France Télévision à le
faire puisque une fois de plus une fois
de plus c'est un sujet qui me tient
vraiment à cœur parce que j'ai un peu
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle les fake
news donc la diffusion de fauses
nouvelles
si on peut laisser cela sans sanction et
si vous ne faites pas la lumière
là-dessus ça décrédibilise tout le
service public audiovis l'investigation
bravo
merci merci
jéci merci en tout cas Stéphanie la
maman de ma d'être avec nous merci ma
d'être là ma déjà comment tu te sens
aujourd'hui bah je suis toujours sous le
choc de ce qui s'est passé parce que je
trouve que c'est injuste que certaines
personnes qui m'ont fait ça sont encore
à l'école et moi je dois rester chez moi
euh
je je me sens encore pas bien j'ai
encore des bleu j'ai encore mal un peu
partout sur le corps et euh je trouve
que ça va très très mais très lentement
et j'aimerais juste que ça ça se
reproduise pour personne d'autre en fait
j'ai envie que ce qui s'est passé
personne d'autre le vive parce que c'est
horrible en fait au quotidien parce que
ça s passé sur
quoioudre qu'est-ce qui s passé bah en
fait les personnes je les connaissais
pas et apparemment il y a 6 mois je les
avais filmé en train de se battre
donc ils ont voulu régler ça aujourd'hui
filmé en train de se battre et donc qui
ça leur avait pas plu oui donc qu'est-ce
qu'elle t'avait dit il y avait un truc
sur les réseaux il y a eu quoi il a des
non c'est des rumeurs des rumeurs et
donc quoi et tu savais qu'elle
t'attendaiit ou pas du tout c'était quoi
c'était un guetapant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé je savais pas qu' était devant ma
salle parce que justement je m je
j'allais en cours d'espagnol donc je
savais pas qu'elle av dans ma salle
selon moi c'est un acte qui a été
prémédité d'accord donc il y a sûrement
un élève de sa classe qui a donné son
emploi du temps parce que les les filles
sont arrivées au moment où elle sortait
de sa salle de cours euh donc elles se
sont jeté violemment sur elle ramené
dans un coin pour commencer à la
tabasser et c'est inadmissible ce qui
s'est passé et c'était combien au moins
une dizaine he une dizaine donc elles te
disent quoi quand elles viennent pour te
tabasser c'est ça comment ça se passe
elles me disent qu'on doit parler
d'accord et après elle me demande si je
les ai traité de [__] et elle
commence à c'est quoi si je les ai
traité de [__] si vous si tu les
avais traité de [__] oui oui c'est
quoi cette affaire parce que tu les
avais traité il y avait eu un truc ou
pas du tout tu non pas du tout en fait
pensais que j'avais j'avais montré la
vidéo que je j'avais apparemment filmé à
des garçons en disant que je les avaient
traité de [__] non c'est c'est c'est
c'est quoi ça donc en fait elle a eu euh
voilà es se sont jetés sur elle à
plusieurs euh parce qu'elle aurait
soi-disant traité cette jeune fille du
coup qui est l'auteur hein de de de
cette agression de de conasse donc
plutôt que de lui demander des
explications elle lui a tapé dessus
voilà et aujourd'hui c'est la seule qui
a été donc euh euh mis à l'écart euh de
donc de l'établissement et pendant ce
temps ben les autres qui sont aussi
présentes qui filment qui rigolent que
ça amuse sont donc à l'école
tranquillement pendant qu'Océane ben
elle
elle c'est incroyable si vous nous
rejoignez à 21h4 c'est d'une violence
extrême tu as été comment vous avez
appris ça parce que on se met tous à la
place à votre place comment vous avez
appris que votre fille était dans parce
qu'elle était inconsciente he quand elle
a été retrouvée c'est ça donc ils m'ont
appelé j'étais au travail bien entendu
ils m'ont dit qu'il fallait que je
vienne la chercher parce que ben du coup
elle avait subi une agression donc moi
j'ai appelé tout de suite son père pour
que lui ben du coup il était plus proche
he de moi donc il a été directement et
au moment où ils m'ont appelé j'ai
demandé qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
comment qu'elle va ils m'ont dit qu'elle
avait perdu connaissance j'ai demandé à
ce qu'on appelle les urgences j'ai dit
appeler les urgence s'il vous plaît et
ça n'a pas été fait ils ont attendu que
le papa arrive pour du coup la
à
l'hôpital donc une fois à l'hôpital donc
lui il s'est chargé donc de de
l'accompagner pour les examens moi j'ai
pris le relais à la suite de cela donc
elle m'a demandé auocéan de
l'accompagner au commissariat elle
voulait en parler mais je pense que
c'était pas une bonne idée parce que ben
finalement la plainte elle a pas pu
aboutir du coup le jeudi 25 parce
qu'elle a fait une crise d'angoisse
elle est tombée on a dû appeler les
pompiers le Samu est arrivé sur place
voilà euh ensuite donc la police m'ont
rappelé le lendemain donc le vendredi 26
pour me
demander comment qu'elle allait et qu'il
fallait absolument qu'on termine cette
plainte pour que ben justement les les
agrresseur soi arrêté
ou c'est incroyable quand on entend
votre histoire donc nous ce qu'on
aimerait savoir et ce qu' aimerait
savoir les téléspectateurs c'est vrai
qu'on comprend pas en fait tu es all tu
es à l'école tu es en quelle classe
seconde seconde d'accord tout se passe
bien pour toi à l'école oui bien tu as
plein de potes tout va bien tu es et je
tiens quand même à rajouter que ma fille
je la dépose à l'école le matin avant
d'aller travailler je la récupère après
même quand j'arrive en retard je lui dis
tu m'attends dans le lycée et tu sors
euh et quand je vois que ça s'est fait
ça s'est produit au sein de
l'établissement je me dis mais on est où
non mais c'est ça du coup moi j'ai j'ai
plus confiance bien sûr je je sais pas
tous les gens qui nous regardent à 21h6
en direct doivent se dire on ils ont
plus confiance non plus donc dans ton
établissement il y a il y a personne qui
a qui qui savait qu' a personne qui qui
a alerté quelqu'un personne non ben
visiblement non les surveillants se
demande ben où ils étaient à ce
moment-là bien sûr voilà à quoi ils
servent du coup pour le coup et donc
toutes ces jeunes filles sont dans le
dans le même lycée dans le même lycée
elles sont pas dans la même classe bien
mais elles sont dans le même lycée elles
y sont elles y sont toujours et elles y
sont toujours sauf celle qui porte les
coups à Océane elle a été exclue mais
conseil de discipline donc avant les
prochaines vacancese discipline et après
du côté police qui va se passer quand
même probablement faut le dire oui
l'avantage c'est comme il y a les images
et que le le lycée a les noms des des
des jeunes filles ils vont les
transmettre à la police et ce qu'il faut
espérer c'est qu'il y a rapidement des
gardes à vue et que les filles qui ont
fait ça déjà une garde à vue quand même
ça impressionne et qu'ell soit qu'on les
qu'on les entende qu'on les interroge et
que la justice des mineurs fasse
rapidement le job hlas la justice des
mineurs en général c'est très long c'est
ça le problème euh mais toi aujourd'hui
tu es tu es tu as peur de retourner à
l'école forcément
euh oui j'ai peur j'ai peur parce que je
me dis que ils ont pas tous été
sanctionnés donc je vais sûrement
recroiser recroiser certaines personnes
et que comme je les ai pas tous
identifiés ça peut se reproduire pour
une vengeance ou autre tu as cru que tu
allais mourir à ce moment-là je me
demandais quand ça allait s'arrêter donc
oui je me disais je me que à tout moment
pouvait sortir quelque chose de leur non
tu étais quand même inconscient oui
est-ce que vous racontez je je me
permets maice c'est quand même ce qui
est assez frappant dans votre votre
plainte c'est que finalement vous tombez
par terre et là vous vous vous avez
encore les yeux ouverts et vous voyez
qu'on continue à vous frapper vous voyez
des des pieds qui continuent à vous
frapper sur tout le corps ça c'est quand
même assez terrible avant de perdre
connaissance quoi c'est c'est bien ça
oui c'est c'est injuste ce qu'elle a
subi moi j'aimerais vraiment que les
parents prennent leur responsabilité qui
deviennent vraiment mais acteurs de
l'éducation de leur enfant justement
est-ce qu'il y a un des parents qui vous
a appelé ou qui vous a contacté pas du
tout rien personne non personne non et
il a fallu que je me déplace dans le
lycée que j'exige un rendez-vous pour
savoir ce qu'il en était s'il y avait
des mesures qui avaient été prises et
j'avais plutôt l'impression de plutôt
les déranger voilà et donc aujourd'hui
ce sentiment que j'ai que j'ai eu
aujourd'hui pour revenir à l'affaire
donc toi tu sors tranquillement de
l'école et il y a quelqu'un qui te enin
pendant l'école qui vient te chercher
qui dit on a te parler elle sort même
pas de l'éco elle est dans l'école qu
sort de classe ouais elle sort de classe
il y a quelqu'un qui vient te qui
vient pour l'agresser tuétais pas du
tout au courant pas du tout non parce
que si je savais ou j'allais prévenir le
prof justement j'allais lui dire
monsieur il y a quelque chose qui se
prépare dites l'heure de partir ou
faites quelque chose donc non je savais
pas en fait c'est pour ça que je parle
de préméditation ouais ça a été organisé
c'est un guetapant ils ont ils savaient
dans dans quelle salle qu'elle était et
elles sont venu l'agresser donc elles
doivent-être tout simplement sanctionner
mais sévèrement non mais très sévèrement
ça doit être à titre
d'exemple mais donc toi quand tu quand
tu la vois arrivé tu tu timagines pas
que ça allait être un tel déferlement de
violence derrière comment tu crois tu
t'imagines pas ce qui va se passer
derrière quand elle viens de parler
parce que quand elle est arrivée je
commencais à descendre les escaliers
parce que je savais pas que c'était pour
moi d'accord et je voyais filmis mais je
calculais vraiment pas parce que pour
moi j'avais de problème avec personne
donc je savais pas que c'était pour moi
je m'apprête à descendre les escaliers
et je sens sa main sur mon manteau mer
que du coup je refuse de porter mais que
j'ai porté aujourd'hui d'accord et euh
je vois que tu essayes de te défendre
aussi hein oui oui bien sûr bah oui
ouais et et c'est là que les autres oui
c'est ça parce qu'en fait comme elle
voit que défend et que tu tu elle a des
difficultés avec toi ils viennent tous
derrière pour pour l'aider quoi en fait
c'est ça même c'est que la plupart ben
elle elle filme ça rigole c'est très
amusant ce qui se passe he non c'est
c'est loin d'être
amusantile ouais non smiley qui se Mar
et tout mais c'est vraiment des abrutis
finis et et etes tes copains et tes
copines du lycée elles tont dit quoi
quand elles t'ont vu partir c'est ça le
truc tu étais toute seule quand tu as
descendu les escaliers tu avais pas de
potes avec toi j' étais avec de deux
amis de classe à moi ouais et on c'était
en intercours donc on s'apprêtait à
descendre les alier et ell comprenait
pas elles m'ont dit mais tu as fait quoi
pourquoi il y a des personnes devant
enfin c'est qui ouais ensuite bah elle
regardait en fait elle regard elle me
regardait parce que elles m'ont dit
qu'elle pouvait rien faire vu qu'il y
avait plusieurs personnes elles ont pas
essayé d'alerter les surveillants ou non
non non elles étaient quoielles ont
elles étaient en train de regarder en
fait elles étaient quoi elles étaient
toute la scène pendant toute la scèneou
ça a duré combien de temps je je sais
pas je pensais vraiment pas à ça à ce
moment-là en fait moi j'ai eu une une de
de vos amis au téléphone justement cet
après-midi qui m'a dit que ça avait duré
à peu près 5 minutes ouais et elle j'ai
essayé de lui parler lu demandaer de me
raconter ce qui s'était passé et cetera
mais je sentais qu'elle était très
fermée enfin on sent qu'elle est hyper
gênée par cette histoire aussi ouais que
peut-être qu'elle s'en veut aussi de pas
être intervenu je ne sais pas vous avez
essayé d'app elle aussi va encore à
l'école vous avez essayé d'appeler
l'établissement oui mais l'établissement
de toute façon dans ces cas-là dans
toutes ces affaires les établissement
ils se verrouill ils disent nous on peut
pas communiquer et il renvoie vers le
rectorat et c'est le rectorat qui m'a
répondu Gill le
l'établissement rien du tout il a fallu
attendre que vous portiez plainte pour
que le directeur consente à vous parler
si j'ai bien lu c'est ça qu'au début il
y avait aucune prise de conscience et
comme vous êtes au commissariat là il
consent enfin à vous parler et c'est
surtout quand je me suis rendu et que
j'ai exigé d'avoir un rendez-vous qu'ils
ont compris et quand j'ai montré les
vidéos c'est là où ils ont pris du coup
ben l'ampleur que que de de la situation
donc s'il y avait pas eu de vidéo final
bien sûr ils aur pas pris en
considération ce qui s'est passé et
c'est euh juste euh Stéphanie vot votre
mari il a il a réagi quandment parce que
c'est vrai que lui il doit être comme un
fou aussi et bien écoutez on essaie de
garder notre oui il faut pour elle bravo
à vous bravo à vous il faut parce que
elle a besoin aussi de se reconstruire
et par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
parce que votre mari au début il a dit
quoi il a dit je je vais je vais tout je
vais tout casser mais moi j'ai dit
pareil ouais ça ouais ah oui oui mais
après quand j'ai vu dans l'état qu'elle
était je pouvais pas me permettre de de
de de
de de pleurer euh voilà je me suis mise
en vous avez pensé à appeler les parents
ou pas du tout
de pas forcément pas forcément je voilà
moi c'était de porter plainte de prendre
contact avec l'établissement et surtout
de médiatiser ce qui s'était passé alors
je vais vous dire là voyez ou pas
typiquement Stéphanie et son mari de mé
ils ont fait tout comme il fallait ouais
et ben on va voir ce qui va se
passer parce que le système est fait
d'une telle manière qu'ils ont peut-être
aussi des enfants donc s'ils prennent
les aides s'ils prennent leur chômage ou
les tout toutes les aides qu'ils peuvent
avoir rest accumulé peu importe tout ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir ils vont faire 1002
1003 et au travail on va leur dire bah
toi on te connaît pas tu as pas de
diplôme ni d'Adam ni d'Ève viens premier
jour 1003 1004 net il va dire je vais
pas aller travailler pour gagner 200 €
de plus je chez le chage non mais il il
y a des gars il y a des gars qui
cherchent vraiment du travail
il y en a énormément j'ai regardé ce qu'
m'a dit à la pub non mais c'est pas
possible mais quand il dit tout ce qui
sort de sa bouche c'est des conneries il
a dit 1450 profiteurs en France mais tu
en as pas marre mais tais-toi tais-toi
tais-toi on peut plus mais c'est pas
possible 1450 profiteurs mais c'est t
ceux qui é la BAR mon fils non mais
qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte comment tu peux dire une
connerie pare ça ça se calcule en
milliards les profiteurs dis millions
person je te parle en argent arentard
des milliards tu veux que je te dise la
vérité ce qu'il faut faire les deux
trucs à faire il faut s'attaquer aux
deux fr la frudte fiscale et tout ce qui
est voilà tu vois peut être intraitable
avec l'évasion fis exctement voilà non
mais tout ce qui est fraude ça déjà tu
vas voir tout ce qui est fraude déjà tu
vas voir si tu et deux il faut
s'attaquer à tous les profiteurs la
fraude sociale exactement tu vois tu
vois tu sais mettre des mes la que la
FRE la
FRE
exactement an mais oui le mec il reste 8
ans sans travailler c'est pas la lo le
permet de faire on lui donne 1000 € dans
sa poche il dit merci la prends je pas
travailler vous croyez sérieusement
qu'il y a des gens qui vont rester 15
ans sans boulot
est en
A50 est
déconnecté galère pas les gens il y a
des gens au chômage vraiment qui galèr
qui doivent se revenir dans le monde du
travail qui qui vivent l'enfer à cause
de leur formation leur diplôme et cetera
ils sont plein de motivation on leur
ferme les portes pour des
discriminations peu importe des
compétences l'âge peu importe ceux-là on
les laisse à part parce qu' ils en
veulent je te parle de ceux de longue
durée me dis pas qu'il galère dis pas
qu' un mec qui prend 1000 balles par
mois et si on lui dit tu vas aller faire
ce boulot là pour 1003 je va aller faire
le je vais balancer des des abonnements
dans le Pass Navigo va fallir que je
mange le midi va falloir que je me
trouve des je vais payer des impôts
derrière je reste chez moi à 1000 balles
t que ça tombe e il y en a pase pas00
ils font des petits boulots à côté ça
existe et voilà oh là là ça existe hein
moi je donne mon avis me créz pas de
chant je je suis un peu d'accord avec
lui mais mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux alors déjà je trouve que radan il a
aucune humanité voilà tu as aucune
humité et ok donc je suis totalement
d'accord la France elle veut pas cuir
tous les malurs du monde mais donné la
France c'est pas des c'est pas des Gogol
genre ils ont fait rentrer des gens ils
sont là maintenant on peut pas laisser
crever c'est pas des animaux même encore
les animaux on on les vise pas là on les
soigne donc à un moment donné non je
suis désolé des bébés c'est c'est c'est
quoi ça d'humanité on est français on
est séngalais on est congolais on est
des humains avant je comprends quand
vous parlez je comprends quand vous
parlez et j'accepte plus j'en peux plus
de Verdez je connais rien à la vie aux
gens des profiteurs il y a que ça
qu'est-ce qui répond à ça au profiteurs
g ver sache-le sache-le la France
aujourd'hui pas000 la France aujourd'hui
je te le dis elle est aussi victime et
et je te dis que c'est bien plus grave
que ce que tu ne crois des profiteurs et
de ceux qui profitent de la France et du
système sache-le alors qu'il y a des
gens qui travaillent énormément et qui
comment tu pe avoir un agriculteur qui
travaille qui prend moins qu'un gars qui
travaille pas mais mais on est où en
fait mais on est où là mais je te parle
des agriculteurs c'est un exemple il a
raison mais il y en a plein d'autres non
mais mais mais tu dis quoi toi tu dis
quoi mais tu dis quoi regardez pas comme
ça mais je dis que tous les gens qui
sont au RSA ils n'ont pas choisi les
chômeurs longue duré il n'ont pas choisi
arrêtez ils ont choisi g par que tu dis
conneries il y en a qui l'ont choisi il
y a une
différenceis d'être complètement qui
l'ont choisi parce qu'il y en a qui
veulent pas travailler avant d'êre r tu
es d'abord au chômage si tu as
travailléas ouver trava pour entre le
moment où et tuarrive au RSA il s'en est
passé du temps souvent il se passe un an
et demi 18 mois dans la plupart dans la
plupart des cas donc les mecs s'ils sont
au RSA depuis plusieurs années c'est
qu'ils l'ont
voului avec le peuple regarde ce que
disent les gens bravo Raymon il y a des
gens qui vont pas bosser car plus chez
eux et plus que les métier passion bravo
rmon connectez-vous Gilles Vernez qui
dit n'importe quoi me de bras trill
quand on a le RSA la mesure de
hatal j'espère que tu es pour c'est déjà
alors attention c'est pas nouveau hein
c'est déjà en vigueur en
202 on va rappeler ce qu'a dit Gabri je
trouve ça aussi c'est très bien et G
Verdez encore le je ve pas dire le
guignol je veux dire Gilles verd ça me
pend au nez ça me brûle la langue Gill
verd que que des guignoleries es contre
en fait parce
queexqu parce que Gil Verdes tu n'as pas
compris pourquoi il est contre parce que
G ver est pour la France de laistana la
Gill Verdez il est pour la France de la
sistana et Gill Verdez il est pour la
France de l'échec c'està-dire que dès
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est en échec ou
qui est en situation de délinquence il
va aller l'aider dès qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui est en situation de travailler et
qui mine de rien a des difficultés il il
est pour les squat les
camboire de sa vie Gill verd Gill verd
c'est le roi de l'échec voilà
écoutez-moi bien c'est le Kasparov de la
télévision champion du mondepar ouais B
champion du monde de la connerie toi ch
alors gabrielal a confirmé qu'il faudra
travailler minimum 15 heur par semaine
pour obtenir le RSA et que la mesure
sera généralisée iici la fin de l'année
bravo Gabriel
conditionneespè je pens pr d'aut
mes compris d'ailleurs pour les gens
effectivement qui sont honnêtes don
parler don parler Raymon qui n'ont
qu'une envie c'est de revenir dans le
monde du travail ça leur permet de
revenir un petit peu dans ce monde du
travail j'aimerais qu'on entende juste
par on va faire ça demain on vaarlerain
j'aimerais juste quand même qu'on
entende pourquoi Gilles Verdez le génie
de l'échec est d'accord n'est pas
d'accord avec cette mesure de Gabriel
Atal écoutez prenez des notes et vous
allez voir la nup c'est contre aussi
hein la nup c'est contre ses amis sont
contre c'est normal ses amis sont contre
donc il est contre voilà non mais ses
amis auraient dit on est contre on est
contre nager avec des des palmes tuba
voilà il aurait dit oui ça s'appelle le
RSA sous conditions on est d'accord et
moi moi je ne veux pas de conditions RSA
le RSA ce sont des gens qui vont toucher
€ 9 pour un coupe sans enfants qui n'ont
rien qui sont à la rue qui sont
incapables de pouvoir pratiquer une
activité c'est très
compliqué laissez-moi finir laissez-moi
finir d'autre part d'autre part il y a 2
millions de personnes qui sont concerné
d'accord pour que la mesure s'applique
il faudra être inscrit à France travail
ancien Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui il y a
que 40 % de ces gens qui le sont 60 %
des gens doivent s'inscrire à France
travail vous pensez qu'il vont aller au
guichet de France travail inrire où sont
les employés les Fran travail arrêtez
France travail va être submergé c'est de
l'utopie totale on peut annoncer des
trucs merveilleux mais ça ne se fera
jamais c'est impossible justement ça
participe d'un retour à l'emploi ça
justement ces gens là qui sont hors du
système et qui sont peut-être
extrêmement malheureux d'être hors du
système on les remet dans ce système en
les mettant en leur demandant de se
connecter justementou d'aller sur France
travail de de retourner à P emploi
qu'onppelle plus P emploi maintenant et
de et de remettre un dans ce me qui
justement étranger et donc le moment
form arrête arrête je t'ai pas donné la
parole ça s'est fait dans 19
départements tous les départements de
France se sont batttu pour avoir cette
mesure chez eux par tellement ça marche
et tellement c'est positif tellement ça
va dans le bon sens tu vois pas mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait lui il a fait
quoi ils ont fait quoi ses amis ils ont
fait que de la merde tes amiss ont fait
que de la merde racte JeanMichel en
train de vérifier parce que je suis sûr
que tu dis une grosse connerie je crois
tu pas obligé d'être inscr à l'emploi
pour toucher Lesa en defier
ça cette nouvelle mesure là il faudra
êtrer
plus il a les bonnes infos il a dit deux
fois n'importe quoi déjà tu es pas
obligé d'être inscrit àemploi pour le
toucher en plus tu parles des gens à la
rue les gens à la rue une problématique
ils ont pas d'adresse eux
malheureusement n'arrivent pas à faire
de démarche et à percevoir des mais le
RSA c'est un CDD de survie c'est pas un
CDI àe le RSA le RSA c'est fait pour
aider les pour aider les gens à
traverser une passe et à se cette mesure
faire rertion parce que c'est le cancer
de la France on en a Mar voilà bravo
arguments c'est c'est la loi et c'est
impossible à mettre en place avec ça on
va aller dans le mur
direct j'ai pas dit d'erreur il faudra
êre
inscrit Ren tu dis que des
conneries ttoi arrête de crier pour rien
tu nous fa le problème de s'inrire au
pôemploi je su
inscritème il s'est arrêé sur le petit
truc mais qu'est-ce qu'il raconte va PIR
absorber un million et quelqu de gens
qui c'est fait tout ça c'est fait pour
que plein de gens n' plus le RS pourquoi
c'est fait aussi pour la réinsertion
parce que pour que les mecs ils aillent
bosser tout simplement g verd mais toi
comme tu es pour la France de la
sistana voilà je le dis et la France qui
qui qui qui de des gens qui profitent du
système voilà pourquoi voil pour ça et
bizarement comme tes amis la sont contre
tu es contre commehabite et ce sont tes
amis bizar tu as toujour les tu les
défends
toujour
[Musique]
amis de la même manière mesure qui est
très
bien je disre mesure mainant qu'on
refusera de CDI de suite sans raison
valable on sera
plus
Contin ils ilst pour ils sont contre ses
amis
cette contre la mesure amis cont mesure
TER regarde g tout à l'heure tu as parlé
de 910 € c'est quoi 910
€ le SMIC pour une personne c'est 1300
déjà pour le couple il que 400 balles
d'écart après si le couple ils ont des
enfants derrière ils vont toucher
d'autres Z tu es d'accord avec moi ont
enfants ça monte déjà là c'est plus la
peine d'aller travailler rideau par que
si tu mets transport si tu mets la
bouffe si tu mets l'impôt sur le revenu
si tu mets la garde des enfants si tu
mets tout réuni ça ça sert plus à rien
d'Er
trava faut cher quelqu quelqu'un qui est
en condition pour aller travailler il
doit pas pouvoir refuser un boulot qui
est qui un petit boulot à 1003 1350 net
il doit pas pouvoir le refuser il doit
pas pouvoir dire jeis à 100 alors je
vais refuser le boulot ça va me faire
gagner 150 € de plus ça sert à rien j'ai
les transports j'ai la bouffe j'ai les
impôts sur reven il reste en moyen 7 ans
c'est pour ça qu'il faut dire
sur tout le monde on va petre aussi voir
les gens qui veulent pas jouer le jeu
celui qui veut pas jouer le jeu qui veut
pas dire à la France regarde moi je vais
travailler je vais payer des impôts
comme unre cel la fête est bientôt
fin non mais Gill il est généreux avec
l'argent qu'on n pas
après il est généreux avec des conneries
ilner pourra 1850 il finit à 21h15 c'est
pas compliqué oui qu'est-ce qu'il non on
pourrait faire comme G on pourrait dire
oui il faut aider les les les les c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire ce qu'il
fait lui que dire nous on va enlever on
va enlever des RSA on va enlever le
chômage on va enlever ceci on va enlever
cela ça c'est ça c'est pour se faire
démonter pour se faire taper dessus il y
a rien mieux mais je pense que les gens
qui vont se lever le matin et qui vont
travailler qu'à 6h ils attendent leur
train qui anulou je sais
et que 20 il dit là j'ai plus rien je
suis à sec et pourant je travaille et on
est le 20 et j'ai plus rien et je vais
faire un découvert que je vais
rembourser le mois prochain c'est que je
suis dans l'engrenage de mon découvert
et la banque elle va me mettre en plus
des agios et le voisin je le vois lui
avec des Nik au pied des survêtements et
en train de gratter des rapidos toute la
journée je peux
pas bah moi je suis venu à l'âge de 14
ans d'accord j'ai eu mon brevet ici
j'étais au collège à losski j'habitaé à
Bologne avant ah ouié oui oui et après
bah j'ai fait un CAP Agent de sécurité
oui et je l'ai eu et entre deux j'ai
fait une erreur que fallait pas le faire
et c'est ça qui a fait que vous étiez
sous auoct oui qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait comme erreur comme ça on dit tout
bah j'étais bah laavé de l'anniversaire
de ma tante là où où je vis chez elle
oui j'ai bah j'étais avec des amis on
était alcoolisé et et bah du coup ils
ont pris euh on était à côté de la moto
ils l'ont pris et de là on s'est fait un
interpell volé moto on l'a pas volé on
s'est fait interpell à côté de la moto
ils nous ont pris pour pourquoi c'est un
mec qui a pris vos potes qui a pris une
moto voilà qui a volé une moto et vous
ées à côté voilà vous étiez dans la
bande quoi oui voilà donc et et derrière
au qtf oui derrière au qtf j'ai eu un
jugement j'ai eu un jugement et le
tribunal il m'a bah il nous a ils m'ont
donné une deuxième chance comme je suis
en étude et j'ai que des bons résultats
que des que des félicitations que j'ai
des soutiens de tous mes profs et bah du
coup et pourquoi c'est quoi alors votre
deuxième chance euh bah j'ai eu un stage
de citoyenneté et une Amand à payé le
juge il l' d aujourd'hui pourquoi vous
êtes encore sous qtf bah je sais pas
j'ai eu une peine et là je j'ai deux
double peine double peine juste d' et et
vous sibora pourquoi vous êtes sous qtf
bah moi c'est quand j'ai eu mes 18 ans
j'ai fait la demande comme majeur j'ai
eu un récipc pendant presque 1 an et là
ils m'ont répondu avec un okitev j'ai
pas vous êtes de quelle origine je suis
albanaise d'accord et vous tunisien
tunisien bon et donc là vous êtes sous
au qtf mais ouis et vous êtes vous êtes
avec votre famille ici je suis avec mon
bah le mari de ma tante qui est français
et ma tante qui est aussi française et
on vit ensemble on partage les mêmes
trucs ensemble lui il est catholique moi
je suis on partage tout ensemble on est
on habite ensemble il y a que de respect
moi je je je vais tout vous dire euh
pourquoi je voulais vous recevoir ce
soir et je pense que pour les télp
spectateur c'est important aussi il est
19h52 on est en direct nous et je vous
dis on a souvent eu le discours ici on
s'est dit pourquoi tous les qtf et rayon
l'a dit
aussi ne soyez ne devez pas devez
quitter le territoire s'il Avaz une
obligation de quitter le territoire il
fallait qu'il le quitte et c'est vrai
qu'on avait envie de voir des profils
parce que quand on vous voit tous les
deux quand on vous écoute on on on se
dit en fait pourquoi vous êtes sous au
qtf maîre pourquoi parce que même s'il a
il est il est vous aujourd'hui tu es
nationalité tunisienneou c'est ça et
vous nationalité albanaise oui c'est ça
donc mais vous vous avez combi un d'lit
ou pas de quoi vous avez combien d'lit
de com vous avez comis un d'lit ou pas
une infraration jamais jamais non jamais
et pourquoi vous êtesous PTF pourquoi
soustf alors expliqueznous merci alors
c'est vrai tout d'abord merci de les
recevoir parce que c'est important on
parle beaucoup de d'qtf en ce moment
dans les médias parle beaucoup
d'immigration qu'on est très souvent en
lien avec Ben tout simplement la
délinquence donc c'est important on y
reviendra peut-être plus tard et c'est
important de voir des visages et de voir
des parcours pour comprendre que parfois
les obligations de quitter les
territoires français c'est pas forcément
pour des personnes qui sont dans la
délinquence ou dans terrorisme nous je
peux vous dire ce qu'on ce qu'on voit
alors je le dis moi ce que j'avais en
tête et ce que ce qu'il avaent en tête
pratiquement tous ici je pense vraiment
c'est pour nous voyez les terroristes
parce que les TER divers c'était souvent
des TF c'était c'était 5000 octf
dangereux et qui on disait qu'il fallait
mettre 10 policiers derrière
nous on avait dit non gensl on va pas
mettre 10 policiers derrière un gars
autant autant qu'il repartent d'où ils
viennent autant quand on sait la
destination d'où ils viennent quand je
vois les deux personnes que j'ai là
qu'on fait des études en France qu' on
passé des diplômes en France eu des
brevets en France c'estes gens-là c'est
du cas par cas ces gens-là ils ont pas à
retourner dans un pays qui est en guerre
ou qu'ils ont fu ou peu importe ou qui
ou qui préfèrent être là Plô qu'en
Tunisie non mais qui préfère être là
plutôt qu'en Tunisie parce qu'il pense
qu'il a une meilleure vie ici moi mon
père quand il est parti du Maroc pour
venir ici c'est pour avoir une meilleure
vie ici c'est
pas merci merci sil vous pla on va on va
y revenir parce que justement ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que quand on a un
refus de séjour donc quand on rentre pas
dans un cas de plein droit donc de
délivrance de tytre de séjour de plein
droit la préfecture peut assortir le
refus de séjour d'une obligation de
quitter le territoire français elle peut
mais dans on va dire la majorité des cas
tous les refus de séjour sont assortis
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français il y a très peu de dossier où
finalement on donne ce qu'on appelle les
refus simples et là dans ces deux
dossiers c'est des dossiers on va dire
plutôt euh habituel mais en même temps
atypique parce que ce sont des jeunes
qui arrivent après l'âge de 13 ans donc
le plein droit c'est avant 13 ans alors
tunisien c'est même avant 10 ans parce
que c'est l'accord franco-tunisien qui
s'applique donc ils ne sont pas dans le
plein droit ils sont arrivés à 14 ans
tous les deux donc pour sibora elle
arrivé on va dire quelques mois trop
tard si elle est arrivée à l'âge de 13
ans elle avait de plein droit un tytre
de séjour c'est pas le cas donc elle
rentre pas dans le plein droit
d'ailleurs on lui délivre un répissé
donc elle arrive à la préfecture elle
dépose son dossier Ré piss et on se dit
qu'avec les résultats scolaires qu'elle
a parce qu'elle a un baccalauréat en
France un brevet elle est en 2è année de
langue étrangère appliqué avec des
bonnes notes que ça va passer qu'on va
tenir compte de son ancienneté de
séjours et son parcours scolaire et non
là le préfet n'en tient pas compte en
indicant que les deux parents sont en
situation irrégulière et que donc elle
peut retourner dans son pays d'origine
sans qu'il y ait d'atteinte à sa vie
privée et familiale et là où où
effectivement c'est un petit peu
compliqué c'est que on va revenir aussi
sur le cas de de de Monsieur amine c'est
que c'est ces personnesl au départ quand
elles sont arrivées en France c'était
pas leur choix ce sont des ce sont des
des mineurs donc c'est le choix des
parents ça aussi il faut peut-être en
tenir compte et elles ont quelque part
déjà une première fois un choix des
parents où on décide de l'changer
totalement de vie et encore une fois
donc là elles vont s'intégrer elles vont
s'investir tous les de que des amis
français avec un parcours tout à fait je
dirais exemplaire on va voir les
résultats scolaires de de Mohamed Amin
les professeurs ont fait une lettre de
soutien en disant il est exemplaire et
pour autant on se retrouve avec des
situations où légalement ils peuvent le
faire POS tous nos téléspectateurs à
19h56 c'est vous avez une obligation de
quitter le territoire français et vous
êtes sur notre plateau ce soir comment
ça se fait bah on fait moi
personnellement je fais attention et là
même quand j'irai à mon lycée et là je
passe mon bac bah j'ai j'ai peur je
stresse même pour aller à mon lycée
c'estàd que là si vous si vous faites
contrôler bah voilà quand vous vous
devezer au CRE de rtion
pour moi j'ai ma tante ici c'est comme
ma mère elle a pas elle a jamais eu
d'enfant et je peux pas le je peux pas
c'est pour ça je suis venu en France je
sais mais euh euh Mohamed vous avez pas
peur là de de vous montrer ce soir en
direct
bah non j'ai peur oui mais j'assume
voilà j'ai j'ai pas le choix j'ai pas si
vous si vous avez un contrôle euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah un centre et
après il me ramène en Tunisie d'
d'accord et pourquoi vous avez quitté la
Tunisie quand vous avz 14 ans ma tante
elle a pas eu d'enfants d'accord V
parents sont Tunis VO mon père estc
j'avais 5 ans quand il était voilà et
bah du coup ma mère elle pouvait pas et
du coup je suis allé avec ma tante pour
qu'elle pour qu'elle m'aide et pour pour
habiter avec elle quoi bien sû et je
suis venu légalement ici je suis venu
avec un visa je suis pas venu par
l'Italie je suis venu légalement mais
voilà alors a précis excusez-moi il a eu
des documents de circulation pour
étrangers mineur c'està dire que toute
la minorité il estéta j'étais en règle
sibora vous pourquoi vous si vous aussi
si vous êtes contrôlé vous aussi vous
retournez est al oui c'est c'est la même
chose oui on a mais en plus vous vous la
alors je je dis tout ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux euh Mohamed ils disent bon
c'est vrai que Mohamed il a des notes
incroyables et cetera il a l'air voilà
franchement mais mais ils disent il a il
a commis une petite infraction euh pour
vous euh ils comprennent pas en fait
pourquoi donc c'est c'est quoi la raison
ah bah elle entre pas dans un casadre
délivrance de plein droit donc on peut
lui assortir le refus de ses jour donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dis voy voyez
commencer moi moi je vais prendre 2
minutes je vais quand même prendre euh
bon la défense du ministre de
l'intérieur vous rendez compte il
faudrait en fait c'est vraiment au cas
par cas vous rendez compte ce qu'il
faudrait faire il faudrait qu'il y ait
des personnes qui soi donc donc nommé
par le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
statuer par le ministère de l'Intérieur
pour qu'il fasse des entretiens avec
chacun des TF enquêtes et des enquêtes
et qui les revoit peut-être tous les 6
mois pour voir comment ils évoluent ou
tous les 3 mois vendez contre c'est
c'est énormément de moyens en fait c'est
ça l'histoire parce que nous là ce qu'on
a fait voilà je suis sûr que
n'importe quelle personne sensée qui
fait un entretien avec Mohamed ou avec
sibora ils se disent bon quand on parle
avec eux ils ont pas l'air d'être un
danger pour la France ils ont l'air
parfaitement inégré ils veulent
travailler ils ont des notes excellentes
voilà donc le l'histoire c'est vraiment
alors problème c'est que dans une loi
c'est on essaie voilà c'est c'est c'est
on essaie de généraliser donc forcément
c'est pas au cas par cas et c'est vrai
qu'il y a certains cas avec certaines
lois et certaines décisions qui doivent
être prises au cas par cas c'est fou on
en a parlé la derère fois sur une autre
décision je sais plus quoi on disit
c'est au cas par cas mais là vraiment
c'est c'est très compliqué vraiment qui
qui j'aimerais voilà qui pense ici que
Mohamed ou sib doivent quitter le
territoire et doivent honorer le r qtf
dites la vérité qui on voit qu'on est
pas
dans dans facea non mais dit ditesle non
mais est-ce qu'il y en a ou pas parce
que c'est comme un moi moi je vous dis
quand je les
vois a des règles ah oui pour vous il y
a des règles il y a des règles il y a
des lois partir il rentre pas dans le
cadre de la loi qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire la la loi la
loi tu lu dis pourquoi tu es sur la loi
c'est vrai elle a raison quand on dit
qu'on est sur la loi la loi la
loi vous vous cachz derrière la lo là
c'est mon avenir est mon avenir qu' est
en jeu là c'est moi s je peux pas je
peux pas avec mon diplôme français je
peux rien faire en Tunisie ils veulent
me ramener en Tunisie pourquoi faire je
vais faire quoi finannée bien sûr non
mais si vous veniez d'un pays en guerre
de Syrie ou de dans notre pays comme ça
en guerre vot vie soit en danger nous on
va en vacances en Tunisie donc j'ai du
mal à comprendre que vous soyez ça soit
ça soit
difficile est
fr bien sûr je sais mon avenir il est en
France si je mais un jour je veux faire
ma vie en France jeux je veux fournir
une famille en France je veux faire tout
en France et pourquoi je j'aurais pas
cette cette chance là seruseé qu'elle
été élevé par sa tente français c'est ça
ce qui nous a dit Mamed ce serait un
drame pour vous de retourner en Tunisie
bien mais bien sûr c'est ça c'est la
pire peine que je vous feriez quoi vous
feriez quoi comment vous feriez quoi
vous avez qui là-bas en Tunisie j'ai
j'ai ma mère et ma sœur d'accord mais
vous pariez quoi si vous
je je sais pas comment je vais finir je
sais je sais pas là même mes amis
d'enfance ça y est je je me rappelle
plus de personne Michel
oui non je sais pas c'est évidemment
c'est des cas par cas mais moi je sais
pas à partir moment où vous n'êtes pas
français pas français vous avez pas de
tit de séjour et ben un moment faut VO
j'étais jeune quand je bah c'est la
France qui m'a élevé à 14 ans je je suis
V moi si j'étais en Tunisie là qu'on me
dise vous êtes pas tunisien vous avez
pas de papier faut repartir en France je
crois que je dirais bah je vais repartir
pas Dr
vous aimez votre pays j'imagine la
Tunisie j'aime la
France je partage les mêmes je partage
les mêmes valeurs que les mêmes de la
République et je voilà on vit dans la
même dans le même pays non non mais plus
franais que
tunisien plus français ou tunisien je
suis plus français que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tunisien